if you're running a startup and trying
to decide how much to charge for your
product
this video is for you at the early stage
just building something people actually
want is such a priority
that deciding how much to charge often
gets kicked down the road
it's easy to say we'll figure it out
later but in many cases
it can make or break your company in
a critical pricing decision almost broke
my company soylent
and today i'm going to share the whole
story with you i'm john coogan and this
is startup pricing explained
i'll start with a little background on
the company i started soyling with three
other co-founders in 2013.
we had all been trying to build other
startup ideas but nothing was working
we were running out of money and every
day we failed to get a new idea off the
ground
was one day closer to having to go back
and get a real job
just as we were running out of money and
it looked like nothing was ever going to
take off
rob reinhard came up with an idea to
help us extend our runway
by letting us spend less money on food
instead of buying ramen like other
entrepreneurs
he bought raw ingredients and started
mixing them together into a
nutritionally complete meal
that he could drink throughout the day
pretty much everyone who encountered his
idea at the early stage
myself included thought it sounded
pretty weird but he decided to blog
about it anyway
the blog got some attention which led to
interviews in popular press outlets
and pretty soon it was clear that we had
to sell soylent as a real product
in order to fund our first manufacturing
run of soylent we set up a crowdfunding
campaign
where people interested in trying it
could pledge their money in exchange for
a box of soylent when we were finally
ready to ship it
in thinking about the benefits of
soiling we settled on three key words
healthy convenient and affordable
typically
food options only satisfy two of these
criteria
nice restaurants are healthy and
convenient but expensive
fast food is convenient and affordable
but unhealthy
and growing your own food is affordable
and healthy but is inconvenient in a
tiny apartment
soylent would uniquely satisfy all three
but making a new product radically
affordable
can be quite difficult when you're a
startup big companies have lots of
advantages when it comes to cutting
costs
generally called economies of scale
large corporations can own their own
supply chains
and purchase raw materials in massive
quantities which earns them a discount
once they've driven their cost of goods
down they have the option to either bank
those
savings as increased profits or they can
get aggressive
and try and lower their prices in hopes
of driving out the competition
when we initially priced soylent we were
hyper focused on delivering value to our
customers
our crowdfunding backers were extremely
excited about the project
and we really wanted to deliver
something great we had a genuine hope
that a low-cost
healthy food could really help people
who were struggling to eat well on a
budget
so low prices were essentially
non-negotiable
to decide how much to charge we did a
simple bottoms-up analysis
where we looked at how much we expected
to spend making the product
and then added the slightest bit of
buffer room just in case things became
more expensive down the line you have to
remember that
when we set up the crowdfunding campaign
we didn't have a contract in place with
a manufacturer
so we didn't have a solid quote for how
much the product would cost to make
unfortunately for us our first cost
estimates were way off
and there was no way we could make any
profit at the price we had originally
set
so we had to raise prices but the
community wasn't too upset
they generally understood that we were
just a small company and we were doing
our best to deliver a great product
but the question of pricing would become
much more important a few years later
in 2015 our company was humming along we
had introduced new products and found
bigger manufacturers who could mass
produce soylent at reduced cost
so we found ourselves in a situation
that big businesses face all the time
should we use those profits to grow our
company or reduce
prices in hopes that more people would
buy our products
to answer this question we turn to a
basic economic theory called price
elasticity
even if you've never taken an economics
class in your life stick with me
because the idea is intuitive but quite
powerful
the elasticity of demand is defined as
the percentage change in quantity
demanded
divided by the percentage change in
price so if the price
of something goes up by 10 and demand
drops by 10
then 10 divided by 10 is one
and the elasticity of demand is
considered unit elastic
things get much more interesting though
when one of these variables starts
moving more dramatically than the other
one classic example involves illegal
drugs because drugs tend to be addictive
drug users will pay nearly any price for
them
meaning the drug prices are inelastic if
the price of a drug
doubles due to enforcement action demand
might only fall by 10 percent
in these situations drug dealers wind up
earning
more money from drug sales and in turn
have greater resources to skirt the
authorities
elastic goods are the flip side of this
coin meaning that just a small
increasing price can dramatically
decrease the demand for a product
luxury items tend to be elastic because
they aren't
essential to everyday life although i'm
sure some extremely rich people may
disagree with me here
in 2015 we believed that the demand for
soylent was elastic
because the food and beverage industry
is so competitive
by radically reducing our price we
thought that we could bring in a huge
number of new customers
and offset any loss of revenues but
there's another important factor to
consider here
margins revenue is important at a
startup
but profit margins are arguably even
more important
since that's what you use to pay your
employees and grow your business
even though we could cut our prices and
potentially increase our revenues
our gross profit would fall
disproportionately
this isn't true for all businesses cloud
software companies
have the benefit of extremely high gross
margins and essentially
zero marginal cost so they can often
give their products away for free in
order to try and maximize the number of
customers they bring in
so how should you price your products if
you're running a startup
well first you need to understand your
cost structure how much revenue does
each customer bring in
and what are your gross margins on that
business you should try and understand
if demand for your product is elastic
or inelastic if you're selling something
that people really need
you might be able to set a high price
without losing that many customers
if the opposite is true and your product
is the elastic you need to be very
careful about price changes
raising your prices even a few percent
could decrease your conversion rate
significantly
it's important to do both bottom-up and
top-down pricing analyses before you
decide what to charge
figure out what it costs you to provide
your product or service to your
customers
and then look at what your competition
is charging once you understand the
competitive dynamics in your industry
you'll be in a much stronger position to
set your startup up for success when you
launch
lastly you can usually change your
pricing strategy
after you launch but be sure not to
alienate your current customers
it's always beneficial to offer existing
customers discounts to keep them on
board
and be clear about how long the new
pricing structure will last
and what motivated the change community
management is important at every startup
and transparency is an extremely
valuable tool to keep early adopters
happy
while you're experiencing growing pains
good luck and if you enjoyed this video
please consider subscribing to the
channel if you have any questions for me
just leave me a comment below or message
me on twitter thanks for watching